في هذه الخيمه كانت تختبئ الطفله رموش
ورفيقتها رحاب من الصواريخ المتساقطه على
مارب قبل ان تنتقل الى غرفه ضنك انها
محميه فوصل اليها صاروخ اودى بحياتهما
ليله اخرى عصيبه عاشها النازحون في مارب
بدات بقصف صاروخي الحوثي وبالطيران المسير
استهدف احدها مستودعا للذخيره ما الداله
تطاير المقذوفات والصواريخ الى انحاء
متفرقه من المدينه المكتظه باكثر من 60
بالمئه من اجمالي النازحين في اليمن
في مدينه مارب بالحوثيين همم اربعه شهداء
من منطقه عمرها خمس سنوات
وفتاه عمرها 16 سنه بالاضافه الى 14 منهم
اطفال هناك
بمصادر عسكريه تحدثت او اكدت على ان هناك
سبعه صواريخ يعتقد ان هذا الاستياء كانت
متفرقه في الاحياء المدنيه في مدينه مارب
وفي مخيم الجفينه وكذلك ايضا وصلت الى
مخيم همم او جو النسيم الذي يوجد فيه
ثلاثه من المخيمات الذي تدير
السيسي ام او ما يسمى باداره المخيمه قتلى
مدنيون بينهم طفلتان وعدد من الجرح ضحايا
القصب الحوثي الاعلى منذ اكثر من عام على
ماربه قصف تسبب بتدمير المساكن في احياء
المتفرقه من المدينه كما وصلت الصواريخ
الى احدى المدارس متسببه بتدمير اجزاء
منها ومحلات تجاريه مجاوره انا مدرسه حادث
امس حادثتها مرعبه جدا في هذه المدرسه همم
الحوثيين همم طغوا وبغواثه في الارض فساد
الحوثيين دمروا مدارسنا مستمرين في في
تعليمنا ولا ترعبنا رصاصهم ولا ترعبنا
صواريخهم مهما كان مهما كان مهما كان وسط
حطام الصواريخ ومن بين ضحاياها المتناثره
يلملم الطلاب في مارب ما تبقى من كتبهم
وهي رساله اخرى لصمود مخيمات النازحين
والمساكن وحتى المدارس اهداف للصواريخ
الحوثيه التي استهدفت الاحياء السكنيه في
محافظه مارب محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه
مارب